[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
14 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my very, very illustrious
colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good, thanks.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty great.
Very excited about today.
We're going to be having
our first episode ever
about storage.
MARK MANDEL: Storage is
a very exciting topic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And very vast.
There's a lot of things
to talk about storage.
MARK MANDEL: It's true.
I think, you know, it's
one of those things
that everyone kind
of has to do it
but may not necessarily
think about it all that much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So yeah, we're going
to have our colleague,
Paul Newson,
specialized in storage.
And he's going to be
telling us everything
we want to know about it.
So very excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But before
that, cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Cool
thing of the week.
I particularly like this one,
as it plays with Kubernetes,
and I like Kubernetes a lot.
One of our fellow Googlers,
Jon Wayne Parrott,
he wrote an article
recently called
"Building [INAUDIBLE]
on Kubernetes"
or "Opinionated Deployment
Tools and Kubernetes."
He built sort of a-- he
calls it a proof of concept,
it actually looks really
interesting-- platform
as a service solution called
Noel on top of Kubernetes,
and sort of looking at how you
can explore Kubernetes to build
some more interesting things.
It's pretty cool.
It sort of sits in that
sort of Heroku-ish space
where you can do a git push, and
it will build things, and then
put it up on Kubernetes for you.
It's quite cool, indeed.
He has a really nice demo
that shows it in action,
where he does a git push.
And then it sort of
builds a docker file
and then sort of takes
that live and builds
a new version of it, kind of
in a sort of App Engine-y type
way, as well.
It's really kind of a nice
mixture of different paradigms
and sort of explores how
you can say, OK, cool,
we have this great
infrastructure of Kubernetes.
What can we lay on top
of that to make things
either better for my particular
use case or just better
overall, maybe?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
No, I really like it.
I went through the article.
The two things that I prefer the
most, by the way, one of them
was the demo itself, which
is built on asciinema.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'd
never seen that before.
I really liked that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I had
never seen that before.
For people listening, it
basically looks like a video,
but it's actually-- so
it looks like a screen
shot of a terminal.
But you can actually
select the text command.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah.
You can see-- like if you
want to copy the commands
the person used.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that's pretty amazing.
And also what I like is the
first phrase of the whole post,
which is, you should be
building on top of Kubernetes.
Seriously.
I really like it.
MARK MANDEL: A sentiment I
can definitely get behind.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I was like, after
that, OK, I'm sold.
It was a good article.
No, but seriously, it's a
very, very good article.
And I think it's very
interesting, especially
because-- if you
want to build on that
on top of "noel," or "nole."
I actually don't know
how to pronounce it.
MARK MANDEL: I call it "nul."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
going to call it "noel,"
because it's like kind of
French for "Christmas."
You know?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Happy.
So either if you want
to use it or not,
I think it's quite
interesting to see
how you can build higher
abstractions on top
of Kubernetes.
How all of these simple
concepts of pods, and services,
and replica
controllers, they all
match together to allow
you to build really,
really cool stuff really.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
yeah, we'll definitely
have the link to that blog post
on our show notes, as always.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So why don't we have a
chat with our friend Paul?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go for that.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
We are joined today by
yet another of our most
excellent of colleagues.
A gentleman by the
name of Paul Newson
is joining us today to talk to
us about storage in the cloud.
Paul, how are you doing today?
PAUL NEWSON: I'm doing well.
Thanks, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
so much for joining us.
PAUL NEWSON: It's my pleasure.
MARK MANDEL: So if
people don't know
who you are-- which
I hazard to guess
is simply not possible-- do you
want to give us a little bit
about yourself, and
your background,
and sort of what you do at
Google, and that sort of fun
stuff?
PAUL NEWSON: Sure.
So I'm a developer advocate at
Google, as you just mentioned,
which means I get to do fun
things like this with my time.
Developer advocate
is one of the titles
that we give software
engineers who
work in developer relations.
So we get to come
out to conferences,
and talk to customers, and give
presentations, and basically
make people aware of the awesome
stuff we have in the Google
Cloud platform, and hopefully
inspire them to use it,
teach them how to use it.
And so I'm very excited
to be here today.
Before I was a developer
advocate for the Cloud
platform, I had the privilege
of working on the Cloud
platform for about three years.
I was a software engineer on
the Cloud Storage team, which
is how I have become known
as the developer advocate who
seems to know something
about storage,
and why you've asked me to come
here and talk about it today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And yeah, actually, that's the
whole point of the episode.
We want to know
more about storage.
And this is our
first episode where
are we going to cover
storage specifically.
And there's so many
options, that we
don't want to make
it like a deep dive
on every single option.
Because the podcast is half
an hour, not half a day.
So we're going to have
to concentrate on, OK, I
have some data.
I want to store it.
What do I do?
PAUL NEWSON: Yeah.
So I'm going to try
to kind of give you
a roadmap, or a decision tree,
about, I have this stuff,
and it kind of looks like this,
so what's the best fit for me?
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Awesome.
PAUL NEWSON: And
there's sort of a couple
of nodes on that decision tree.
First, let's talk
about your data.
Which is, is it structured
or is it unstructured?
If it kind of looks
like a table-- you know,
it has rows and columns?
Roughly speaking, you're
looking at structured data,
and we have a number
of options for that.
If it's just a big bag
of bytes, and you're
sort of handing it
to us and saying,
here's a big bag of bytes,
please store this for me,
I'm going to ask for it later,
that's unstructured storage.
So to a first
approximation, you can
think of the
unstructured storage
like images, videos, zip files.
You know, there's probably
internal structure
to these objects.
But as far as the storage
services are concerned,
it's just a bag of bytes.
And we're just going
to faithfully reproduce
these bytes in the same
order you gave them to us
and hand them back to you.
So in terms of a-- and then kind
of the other dimension, which
we can sort of look at
the different options
you have, are fully managed,
no ops, cloud native storage
services versus I want to
run my existing storage
infrastructure, which I'm
running on my own servers.
I just want to run
that in the cloud.
So we kind of have the lift and
shift versus the cloud native
approach.
So if we're talking
about cloud native,
unstructured storage,
that's kind of the simplest
conversation to have.
If you are a developer--
which, if you're
listening this
podcast, I'm assuming
is the case-- you're most
likely going to use Google Cloud
Storage for that.
Because that's the one
where your application
is in control of the data.
There's a conversation to
be had about Google Drive
and where that fits into this.
So if your application--
you're adding something
that kind of looks like a
new app alongside other apps
that are being
used, and you want
to interact with data that's
stored in spreadsheets
and Docs, or maybe
your own file format,
but it kind of looks and feels
a lot like Docs or Sheets does,
there may be a place for
Google Drive in that scenario.
But I'm going to assume, for
the rest of this conversation,
that Google Cloud
Storage is going to be
your unstructured option there.
And that's in terms of the fully
managed, fully hosted, no ops.
You just store the stuff,
and it's our problem
how to serve it up when
you ask for it later.
If you're looking for more
of a lift and shift solution,
you can easily run whatever your
existing solution is on RVMs.
And we have persistent disk
in a variety of flavors.
That can be used to store that.
There's a lot more ops
overhead to doing that, right?
Because you need
to be aware of, you
know, how is my data
replicated across multiple VMs,
so I don't have a
single point of failure
if I'm using something
like local SSD?
There is-- if you are
using a persistent disk,
then you're not going
to necessarily lose
the data if there's a
problem with a particular VM.
But you may have an
interruption to being
able to serve that data
while you bring a new VM up
to attach that persistent disk.
So that's kind of your
options for unstructured data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have a
quick question about structure
versus unstructured.
The way you described
it was kind of like,
if it has columns,
it is structured.
And if it's just a bag of
bytes, then it's not structured.
What about a bag of JSONs?
PAUL NEWSON: Um, that's
an interesting question.
MARK MANDEL: Semi-structrued.
PAUL NEWSON: It kind of depends
how you're going to use it
and how you want to be able
to look up those JSONs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
PAUL NEWSON: So
if you-- I kind of
view JSON as an
interchange format,
in that-- for example, when
you load-- when you send
a roll of information
to BigQuery, to load it
into BigQuery, you give it
to BigQuery in JSON format.
So you could arguably
say that BigQuery
is storing a whole
bunch of JSON data,
because that's how you
gave it to BigQuery.
But really, it's not.
That was just the
interchange format
that you used to hand
the data to BigQuery
so it can figure out
which pieces of data
fit into which columns.
There are databases which are
kind of native JSON databases.
I'm not super
familiar with them.
So I'm not going
to talk about them
and say something incorrect.
But if you are super
familiar with one of those,
and you understand how to run
it in a high availability way,
you know, again, you can
run those types of solutions
on compute engine VMs, and
you have all the advantages
of running in the cloud.
But there's a lot more
ops overhead on you,
because you're the one who's
setting up that software.
You're making sure
that you have the right
OS patches, you know, and
so on, and so on, and so on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
PAUL NEWSON: So did
that actually address
the question you were asking?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
OK, so then we've
covered a little bit
where to store it when the
data is not structured.
So just, as you said, I
really liked that expression,
the bag of bytes.
What if I have something
more structured?
PAUL NEWSON: All right.
So if you have something
more structured,
we have a few-- we have
a few options for that.
I'm going to say that,
with no other information
at my disposal, except
that you're saying,
I've got some structured
data and I'm building an app,
the go-to answer is
going to Cloud Datastore.
Cloud Datastore is a
structured, NoSQL database.
It scales gracefully, in terms
of both performance and cost,
from zero bytes up to terabytes.
And it has a very
flexible schema.
You don't have to define
your schema up front.
This Cloud Datastore is
available as its own standalone
service, but it was
born as the data store
solution for App Engine.
So it's really,
really well optimized
for these serving
scenarios, where
you have relatively
small pieces of data
that you want to
look up by keys,
and there's structure within
that data, in that you
have individual properties
within each of these rows.
It gives you some limited
querying functionality,
and it also has some support for
cross row transactions, which
can be very important
for certain applications.
So with no additional
information,
I'd say go with Cloud
Datastore is probably
the answer you want.
But the other thing I would
put up for your consideration
is if you have-- if you're
working in a context
where you have
very deep knowledge
of relational databases, and
you want a relational database
solution, because that's
what you know how to program,
that's what your staff
knows how to program,
or you want to take
advantage of some
of those features like
relational integrity
and a very structured
data model,
then you should also look
into Cloud SQL, which is
a fully hosted MySQL solution.
The Cloud SQL solution, there
are now two generations of it.
I would encourage you to look
into the second generation.
It's not generally
available at the time
we are having this
interview, but you
should go to our
website and see if it's
generally available now.
It's certainly
available for you.
It's in beta right now.
You can go play with it.
And it is very scalable.
It can handle a
lot of scenarios.
For most applications,
it's probably
going to be
sufficiently scalable.
It's only if you are
expecting a runaway success,
and you're going
to need to scale
into the terabytes
of data, that you
may find that it doesn't scale
high enough for your needs.
So that's kind of the SQL
versus NoSQL node of the tree.
If you are heavily into
relational databases,
you love relational
databases, we
have a hosted service where
we handle the operations.
And that would be Cloud SQL.
If you are far more
comfortable with the NoSQL way
of doing things, then Cloud
Datastore would be your choice.
So those are kind of
the two go-to solutions.
But there's a third one, a
third structured solution
I should talk about,
which is Cloud Bigtable.
Cloud Bigtable is kind of a
lower level NoSQL solution.
It is also a NoSQL solution.
But we're talking about
really heavy machinery.
The guidance we give
is that, if you're
storing less than a
few terabytes of data,
Cloud Datastore is
probably the way to go.
In terms of when to consider
moving to Cloud Bigtable,
we recommend sort of an
approximate 1 terabyte
minimum of data
before Cloud Bigtable
is going to be a cost effective
way to start storing your data.
The other hurdle to
consider with Cloud Bigtable
is that you are using
a lower level API.
Whereas with Cloud Datastore,
you have a SQL like language
that you can use, if that's
something you're familiar with.
It also has some
higher level libraries,
which you can use to access
it, like the NDB library
that's available as
part of App Engine.
With Cloud Bigtable,
you're using the HBase API.
Which, if you're familiar
with it, is great.
And if you already have a bunch
of existing code which uses it,
then this is exactly what
you should be looking into.
However, it is a
lower level API.
It basically gives you sort
of put, get, scan semantics.
Not higher-- there's no
cross row transactions.
There's no sort of query
language or anything like that.
It's very much a low level
put, get, scan sort of API.
MARK MANDEL: Is there like
particular applications,
or particular types
of data that would
be very-- that are
usually used in time
something like Bigtable?
Like there's a
particular use case?
That's the words
I'm looking for.
A particular use case that
this would be pertinent for?
PAUL NEWSON: Well, the
other characteristic
that Bigtable has, which
is really, really nice
for some scenarios, is
extremely low latency.
Single digit,
millisecond latency,
in the 99th percentile
for reads and writes.
Which is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
PAUL NEWSON: The other thing
that Bigtable gives you
the opportunity to
do is mix your--
what I'd call your serving
workloads with your analytics
workloads-- on one database.
Which is often very
difficult to do.
This is why people have
data warehouses, right?
You have your
operational database,
which is kind of your
serving database, the one
that your mobile
app or your website
is hitting, and getting
the most up to date data.
And then you sort
of replicate that
into another analytics
system, which
has a slightly older
view of the data.
And then you run your
analytics on that.
With Cloud Bigtable, the
latency is low enough
you can use it as
your operational--
as a fantastic
operational database.
You can also, for example,
just run a map reduce
or a data flow directly
against your Bigtable.
And if you provision your
Bigtable with enough resources,
it can handle both
the Analytics workload
and the serving
workload simultaneously.
So if you have a scenario
that looks like that,
Bigtable is definitely
worth looking into.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
So we've seen structured
versus unstructured.
So for unstructured, we
said that cloud storage
is going to be probably the
best solution, in general,
like the go-to solution.
For structured, depending on
how much you structure it-- so
you may go with SQL and NoSQL.
And for NoSQL, we said that if
you really want the real thing,
and you have a huge
amount of data,
and you want
amazing performance,
then you should
consider Bigtable.
But otherwise,
data storage should
be the go to solution
for most of the cases.
PAUL NEWSON: Yep.
And that's all true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So what about when
you want to run
something slightly different?
Like you're saying, yeah, OK.
So if you have NoSQL, you
should go with data store.
What if I'm already running
MongoDB or stuff like that?
What good people
should do for those?
PAUL NEWSON: Yeah, again, you
can just lift and shift those
into the cloud.
We've got these great VMs.
You can choose the VM
size that you want.
You can cluster
it in whatever way
you want that your
favorite package, you know,
allows you to do.
You can choose to run it
on the hard drive backed
persistent disk, the SSD backed
persistent disk, or local SSD,
depending on how much
performance you want
and whether the software
package you're using
gives you the
resilience to failures.
But again, now
you're not talking
about a cloud native, no
ops, fully managed solution
at that point.
Like there's a lot more
responsibility on you
to understand what's going on.
It's just like running
it on your own machines.
It just-- it happens to be
running on our machines,
instead.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I see.
MARK MANDEL: We've talked in
the past kind of like computer
as a continuum.
This is almost like--
this is pretty much
storage as a continuum.
PAUL NEWSON: Yeah, basically.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you want
us to run everything for you,
and manage it and all
that stuff for you?
Or do you want to just create
your own persistent disks
and worry about what the IOPS
are on this particular SSD?
PAUL NEWSON: Right.
So there's one other-- there's
one other structured storage
solution we have, which is
definitely worth talking about,
and that's BigQuery.
A lot of people will
approach our platform,
and they'll look at
the storage selection,
in the storage section
in our console,
and they won't see
BigQuery there,
because it's hiding
under Big Data.
Where it should be, because it's
a really great analytics tool.
That is its natural home.
So a lot of people won't
think about using it
as a storage medium.
But it's actually a fantastic
way to store your data.
It costs you the same per
byte to store archival data
in BigQuery that it would
cost you to store it
in Cloud Storage, durable
reduced availability
class of storage, for example.
The price of those two types of
storage is the same per byte.
But by storing it
in BigQuery, you
can run a SQL query against it.
And you can run massive
SQL queries against it.
And talking about the
continuum of computing,
the continuum of
storage here, you
don't need to say-- you
don't need to tell us,
when you run a BigQuery
query, oh, by the way,
I'd like you to dedicate 10 to
32 core servers to this query,
please.
And I need this much throughput.
You just give us your query--
you give us your data.
Then you give us your query,
and we give you the answer
as fast as we can.
And we have these
very large clusters
that are already
provisioned, which
are this sort of
massive shared tenant
solution, so that-- you know,
what I'm running my query,
I get to chew up a huge
portion of those resources.
And then my query is done.
In the next 10 seconds,
someone else's query
is taking up those resources.
So you get these
sub-minute slices
of time on these huge
analytics clusters
to answer just the
question you're asking it.
It's really quite
an impressive model,
and I encourage you
to-- particularly
for data that is not on
your serving path, data
that you are going
to primarily use
to gain insights from-- put it
in BigQuery and keep it there.
And then you can always do
these ad hoc queries against it,
in the SQL language that
you and your analysts
probably already know and
are very proficient with.
Now, somebody might
say, but wait,
I need to run a
dataflow against it.
Because I'm doing
something like building
a machine learning model, for
example, which I can't do.
You know, I've got to
run my own custom code,
and I can't do that in SQL.
And there are some
features of BigQuery
where you can plug
code in, but it
is far more structured than
what you could do in something
like Dataflow.
So in that scenario, that's OK.
You can still read all of your
information out of BigQuery
in your Dataflow job--
or your MapReduce job,
if you're using Dataproc
with our connectors.
So you're not limited to only
using SQL for your analysis.
So there's really no reason
to not store your long term
archival analytics
data in BigQuery.
That's where you should be using
it for your data warehouse.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
OK, so I think that now I almost
understand all our options
that we have for Cloud Storage.
So just to go over all
of them quite quick,
we made a distinction
between what we're saying
is pretty much managed
in Cloud Native.
And we still have a bunch of
other possibilities, which
is like you build
it on top of VMs,
and you install whatever
you feel like it.
But for the ones that we
propose as Cloud Natives,
we have Cloud Storage
for unstructured
and then Cloud SQL for
SQL, Datastore for NoSQL,
and Bigtable for NoSQL
that runs incredibly fast.
MARK MANDEL: And it's huge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it's huge.
And then we also have BigQuery,
which I really had not
think about a storage solution.
But I really-- yeah, I
can definitely see it.
I really like it.
MARK MANDEL: It's
interesting, actually.
You could almost
say that BigQuery
sits in a weird space
between like SQL and NoSQL.
Because you can do fun stuff,
like query JSON out of it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But still have
a schema at the same time,
if you wanted to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: BigQuery's
kind of an amazing product,
actually.
It's in the middle of
many, many, many cool tools
that we have at Google.
Cool, so is there
anything else that you
would like to mention before
we finish with this interview?
PAUL NEWSON: That's
a fine question.
Let's see.
Well, we've touched on
the big managed services.
I guess the one thing
I'd like to leave
is, there is definitely a
place for lifting and shifting
existing applications into the
cloud as a way to get a win out
of using the public
cloud without having
to do a lot of redevelopment.
So I certainly don't
want to discourage people
from doing that.
However, if you're
writing something new,
I highly, highly,
highly encourage you,
even if it's not what you're
currently familiar with, to,
instead of doing
a lift and shift
where you're running your
own thing on your own VMs,
and you're taking on all
that operational burden,
I highly encourage
you to see, can I
build my application on these
Cloud Native, fully managed,
no ops solutions?
Because they will allow you to
scale very, very high, very,
very easily, without hiring
an equal number of humans
to the amount you
scale to manage
the operations of these things.
So if you are approaching the
cloud and doing something new,
I highly encourage you to
preferentially investigate
the fully managed, no ops
solutions we have to offer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I definitely agree
with that, especially
not only for storage,
but also for computing,
as we were talking.
If you were able to run
your code on App Engine,
it will pay off very, very soon.
Because you don't need to
manage absolutely anything.
So yeah, that's a great
piece of advice, I think.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Well, thank you very much
for joining us, Paul.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
PAUL NEWSON: It's
been my pleasure.
Thanks a lot for
having me on the show.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
And I'm sure that we will
have more storage related
episodes in the podcast soon.
So see you soon.
PAUL NEWSON: All right.
Thanks a lot, guys.
MARK MANDEL: Cheers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Bye.
So thank you very much, Paul,
for this amazing interview.
I learned a lot.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, actually, I
know that this is the first
episode of a series of episodes
where Paul is going
to be here explaining
a bunch of stuff on storage.
Because there's a lot of
things that are really useful.
And at the end of the
day, everything we do
is, you process data, and
then you store it somewhere.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
very important topic.
OK.
So let's go for our third
section of the episode--
the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I think that you
got a pretty good one today.
MARK MANDEL: I think so.
It's probably a topic that
some people have definitely
heard around the traps.
The topic was brought up
directly to me by a gentleman
by the name of Jeff Schnitzer.
Started talking about using
Java 8 in standard App Engine.
It's a long discussed topic
of monumental proportions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But
what sort of options
do you have if you want to start
using Java 8 on App Engine?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So the quick answer is Java 8
on App Engine doesn't work yet.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On
classic App Engine,
what we call normal App Engine.
But, if you want to, you can
use it directly on managed VMs.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So it's something
that works really
well, and you can get
all the nice things of Java 8.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Now the
thing is that we are actually
working on having Java 8
supported on the standard App
Engine.
But App Engine is a
pretty complex product,
has a different runtime.
We changed a little-- we make
it so it's very safe, and scales
very well.
So that takes
engineering effort.
MARK MANDEL: It's
not an easy process
by any stretch of
the imagination.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But we're
definitely working on it.
We know that people want it.
And, I mean, we're
developer advocates,
so we're definitely
pushing also.
MARK MANDEL: We
appreciate it, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
also pushing internally
to make sure that this happens.
And it will happen.
When?
Well, we cannot really say
a date, but sometime soon.
I hope very, very
soon, but who knows?
But, in the meanwhile, I've also
heard that there is actually
some way of getting to feel
like you're using Java 8
without actually having it--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So, obviously, standard App
Engine, you're only limited--
or you're limited to Java 7.
But there's a great project
out there called Retrolambda.
So while you don't get the full
features of everything that
comes in Java 8, if you want
to use the lambda expressions,
but still have it
fall back to Java 7,
you can totally do
that within App Engine.
We promote this all probably
a lot more within Android,
because of the Java
7 requirements there.
But no, you can totally
use it on App Engine.
It's going to make your
syntax a whole lot nicer,
especially if you started
playing with lambdas
a lot more in Java.
And it'll work down to--
it'll work down to Java 7.
So if you haven't played with
it within your GA standard
applications with Java, I
reckon give it a fun go.
I think it will be a
really pleasant experience.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And if you really
want to have actual
lambdas, which
are real lambdas, and
closures, and things like that,
you can also just migrate to go.
Nah, just kidding.
MARK MANDEL: Not that
you're biased in any way,
shape or form.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So yeah, we'll have a link to
the GitHub repo for [INAUDIBLE]
the show notes.
So you can have a look at it.
Great.
So before we finish,
as usual, where
will you be next time
we speak together?
MARK MANDEL: I will be-- so
coming up in a couple of weeks,
I think it is-- yeah,
it is a couple of weeks.
LAUNCH Hackathon on
the 26th of February.
I will be there.
I will be at GDC.
That is ramping up.
We're going to have
a great Google booth,
super excited about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely come by.
We're going to have Cloud Spin.
We're going to have all
sorts of fun stuff happening
at that event.
So that's going to be awesome.
And then after that,
I will be at Strata.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: How about yourself?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by the
time this podcast comes out,
I will be flying across the
ocean coming back from Dubai.
So there is GopherCon Dubai
that will happen yesterday,
when this podcast comes out.
On February 23rd, there
is GopherCon in Dubai.
And after that, yeah,
it's going to be
quite a busy month with
South by Southwest, GDC here
in San Francisco.
And there's also a
Droidcon in San Francisco.
And all of those things,
of course, same week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Oh yeah, I'll be
at GCP NEXT, too.
This is how much stuff's
on, I completely forgot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And GCP next, yeah.
So yeah, it's going to
be a fun month in March.
Yeah.
Looking forward to April.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, very much
looking forward to April.
My birthday is in March, too.
I'd completely forgotten that.
Wonderful.
Well, thank you very much for
joining us yet again, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you very much.
And, as usual, if you
have any questions,
any suggestions, any
comments, free to contact us.
I don't think we
need to do it today.
Do we need to do it today?
MARK MANDEL: I think
we're OK today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I think we're OK.
Let's do it next week.
MARK MANDEL: We'll
do it next week.
Wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
yeah, contact us.
We're very happy to
hear from all of you.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And, as usual, thank
you so much for being
here with me today, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thank you Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]